have you thought of this actually like
let's say someone comes in here grabs
this and walks out what are you going to
do well it's a duplicate so there's not
actually any of the chips in it so see
that's why I asked this is not actual
but Nvidia would be upset and charge us
probably however okay I
see all right sorry about the poor
quality live stream we're going to dive
into the sponsor boost again and then
later we'll do a poster session how
about
that
that lab they still have a company but
apparently they recognized people look
there's
look deep mines but there's Demis Demis
escaping to us can't be bothered to be
here it's just on the screen I know what
to do so many Financial companies here
here's Market there sit down I think
what I struggle with is actually what I
can do the most well because and um and
Dallas like there's a real Hub of like
software engineer Community there and a
few finance companies have
made some of the finance companies here
yeah it's yeah you never see them in
like papers and stuff but then they come
here and they they grab people they hire
them you never see the people again
again look again quantity
trading hi how's it going have y great
um I'm a I'm a brand Parker so I'm the
one non Tech person on this bus uh like
imp poster you know cool what are you
doing here I'm just uh reporting a bit
from the conference so why would anyone
work here and not at this trading firm
or this trading firm or that trading
firm or that several cool uh features of
our company we're just 4 years old uh
but we're really rapidly growing yeah uh
we are more than 140 people now we are
totally investor free we don't have any
external money and we don't accept any
external money we are uh trading only on
our money from this scratch we have
really strong quantitative researchers
team and we're using machine learning we
don't have any manual trading machine
learning was focus on deep learning and
serious analysis all the team can code
including office managers like we had
hackaton for the whole company in non
Tech category like it was hackaton for
all like for everyone but there were
different streams uh for like winners
and on text stream third place took
office manager from Dubai it was her
first time coding in Pyon ever in life
but she could do this like the easiest
strategy so he did it what you're doing
the company as it is there is a pot of
money you're coding machine learning
code to invest that pot of money into
markets with the goal of growing the pot
of money yes and also to provide
liquidity on the markets yeah yes yes
and also like creating you medicine use
of machine learning and de learning and
developing this also the field itself
not just only for making money because
we have a lot of researchers that's
really good at the field not just
because they're City and trying to earn
some money in for St trading it's just
one of the fields that can use it yes
that's fair so yeah and also we have
full merch we have like really nice
working culture we have our average age
of in place 30 years yeah so we're kind
of young people uh full of energy it's
really cool to work with some like you
know nice uh energized people with some
really nice jokes yes yeah a well thank
you so much you're
welcome here's Lambda are these actual
h100s yeah they are so we're looking at
200k or something like this right here
even more nice and then we have the GH
200 over there too that's pretty a neat
shap and you bring this just to
flex I've never seen the heat it's not
mine well it's soon mine I guess if you
look away a
bit you might be able to make it to the
the street have you thought of this
actually like let's say someone comes in
here grabs this and walks out what are
you going to do well it's a duplicate so
there's not actually any of the chips in
it so see that's why I asked this is not
actual but Nvidia would be upset and
charge us probably okay I see but they
very cool so you rent these out yeah we
do yeah and we sell the physical
infrastructure as well so if you want to
purchase these to own and like deploy
yourself on premise or in our Co
location we do that too cool very nice
all right there is Astra
zenica and they Pres presumably do some
health stuff I guess I'm not really into
health I'm a very unhealthy person in
general and here is Bosch hi hi all I
know of Bosch is that they make like
drills and when I see Bosch AI I imagine
like a power drill with like an llm in
it and I need to prompt it to start
dring is that what you do yeah that's
what people we have also Foundation
model for dishwasher go drill things
step by step and it will like start
drilling no yeah that that's the we are
getting a lot like do you put the
foundation models into the dishwasher so
these are the question we are usually
getting but I mean uh so we can talk to
uh like on a practical example like
autonomous driving so autonomous driving
is usually based on the sensor like can
be camera lar but then you don't really
uh you still can't really achieve that
fully autonomous driving because it
can't drive like a human right like but
to achieve like drive like a human you
need to go beyond the like the the you
know those conventional methods yeah and
that's where for example we can kind of
bring the reasoning capability of let's
say large language model Vision language
models to actually achieve let's say
fully autonomous driving and that's what
we are doing like now for example we try
to see how we can actually bring let say
language model into autonomous driving
and this way it's not going to be only
captioning like where just kind of
commentate about let's say possible
action for example if it's making a turn
we want to know why it's making that
turn also we want actually to to improve
the like that turn her problem like so
that's what actually how we are doing
this for for our products pretty cool
yeah big SN day thank
[Music]
you Apple very
fancy very
minimal what you expect like an Apple
Store learned about from your videos
that's like a thing I use a lot so yeah
ni
[Music]
oh wowy me I'm a big
fan sorry we didn't mean interrup your
video
[Music]
there is
IBM okay look at this is
like St Stars an equal crew
here look giant group of people Yan Lon
in
the
but we have no idea how to train robot
to share up the
video this is something that barel
about